merci maryse est sur le chemin de l'onu
kofi annan le secrétaire général a fait
escale hier soir à paris nos équipes
l'ont suivi et ont obtenu sa première
interview après la signature de cet
accord si longuement négocié richard
biner et philippe harrouard bravo encore
bravo c'est avec ses deux simples mots
que le président jacques chirac
accueilli hier soir kofi annan à son
retour de bagdad pour un dîner qualifié
à l'elysée l'informel en fait une
manière pour le secrétaire général de
l'onu de rendre hommage à la diplomatie
française favorable dès les premières
heures est aussi politique et la crise
il ya eu beaucoup de pression y compris
les contacts presse de chirac et a eu
avec mais s'est estompée des limited
daigné t elle très important de dignité
pour ça qu'on n'a pas bien compris en
détresse suivant quelle irak était isolé
s'il est le sien que nous aussi nous
sommes usés l'on comprend pas exactement
comment il faut plan et bagdad
ce matin en quittant la france kofi
annan le ghanéen kofi annan le discret
s'est autorisé ce petit si inhabituelle
à l'adresse des photographes n'ont pas
le v de la victoire
mais le geste simple d'un homme de paix